you ever hear hugs not thugs
these two psychos right here they're
gang members isn't that the place that
reforms gang members yeah and sometimes
we don't do our job right and they don't
get reformed
my cousin spent the last eight years in
prison sorry i'm late i'm just trying to
help him but that won't listen to me
flat 2005 it'll always be 2005 up here
my boy
[Music]
louise tells me that as the older cousin
he would bully you and make fun of you
how do you feel about that it's really
not a big deal
it's not thugs the gang members i help
perform get a second chance at life
people love buying cupcakes from ex-gang
members i thought you said i'd be
designing solar panels and [ __ ]
[ __ ] do you want me to relapse did you
buy a cupcake
thank you red velvet is an amazing
choice
all billionaires are pigs julio i'm
tired of begging for their scraps oh
dominic no no no need for that today
that's okay they're reformed
harmless now
[Music]
[Music]
do you fools am i moving your car i'm in
the middle of a porn race right now
i'll just go around
[Music]
just admit it you miss me so you think
you know me huh you're 31
and you still live at your mom's house
and you broke up with me because you're
scared of commitment
admittedly
you got some serious psychological
issues
sooner or later you gotta face that
devil inside yourself i'd rather die
than let you fools walk all over me i
got a lot of work to do on myself and i
don't want to do it
you're thinking me more as a cautionary
tale than a role model
[Music]
[Applause]
what's wrong with them
[Music]